đợi câu mực tí nhé
được là kiện này là cho cả sai ở bên kia
hay không
Ừ đợi tí nhé
ừ ừ
à à
nhỉ vào cài được TP tôm chưa nhỉ
anh khác
Mình mình sẽ không thông báo ở bên kênh
Tru Tiên là lời đâu trừ khi nổi liên
quan đến đồ án thôi còn không mình sẽ
chủ yếu thông báo ở bên Jesus cool
riêng cho this code để em thử vào với
link này xem nó vào bộ cái thư mục Mỗi
cài vô rách này hay vào cả tôi trách
trên công ty của anh nữa vì anh đang mở
Kaito mà chạy cả cốc trên công ty
em nhắn quá địt con nha
thử vào Link để xem thử xem mà có truy
cập được quyền là vào được cả tôi trách
trên công ty không
một bể Cốt trên công ty ở tôi được nhà
tôi không cho mày không xem được rồi
sau đó thì chắc là lớp trưởng Hòa 1 bạn
là nó bất kỳ nữa cũng được tạo linh linh
Google Mít để mấy bạn à cho bạn lớp
trưởng đi vẫn bạn ơi đi tạo nên Google
Mít để các bạn truy cập vào vào xem nha
Vào xem các bạn để chia sẻ màn hình chứ
Cái này có thể giới hạn quyền đấy nếu mà
thật ra hôm trước thì tội Lo thế nhưng
cuối cùng thì cũng chỉ có mỗi
chưa đến 30 bạn hai mấy bạn xem đấy thôi
Lê Hoàng Lưu Của Hoàng lưu là em nữa
phép mình trả lời câu hỏi trước đã vì
hôm hôm nay tôi là không có tâm sự gì cả
nhưng mình nghĩ là nên phải trả lời câu
hỏi vì có nhiều bạn hôm trước có thắc
mắc thì con mình sẽ giải đáp hết đã
gồm những gì cha chỉ có mỗi cốt của khối
trách này thôi đúng không không không có
nhảy sang cốt của trang khác nữa
Khi bữa nay vẫn cho như bình thường
nhưng mà có vẻ nó hỏi lại quyền như này
tra là cứ lần nào lại phải cho lại hỏi
lại quyền rồi
Ừ Ok Thế
em em tạo một linh Google mít nữa để các
bạn nào mà không không ngon bằng máy
tính không cả cho cả TP Tôm đúng không
Thì thì lớp trưởng hoa cà bạn nào đó bạn
để chia sẻ màn hình xong rồi cũng phải
hơi bị chiều các bạn ấy tí là các bạn ấy
bảo mở file gì thì mở hộ các bạn đấy xem
tôi đã tôi vẫn dậy tôi không thể mở một
lúc một đọc file mày không được vì hôm
nay bắt đầu nhiều pha đấy Hôm nay mình
sẽ làm à toàn bộ xem thêm sửa xóa said
you'd
thì chắc chắn nó sẽ giữa nhiều file
thì cạnh hôm nay mình bị nói trước mấy
cái đầu tiên là thứ nhất là
ờ ờ nộp CV này ở Tôi sẽ chuẩn bị có bài
tập về nhà cho mấy ông đó tớ sẽ
chắc là khó tả đến khi là đến gần đến đồ
ăn hay thì tôi sẽ yêu cầu mấy ông làm đó
là tôi sẽ bắt mọi người viết cv để tội
để đâu duyệt
Ừ Nó là một cái rất là hay ở điểm là
không không cần phải mấy ông học của tôi
mấy ông đôi khi cũng thích người khác
xem qua và đánh giá suy vi của ông viết
như thế nào Cái nếu công nhận ra bạn để
mấy ông xe mà kiểu
nó thực sự là thế nào khi ở một con mắt
người cứ cho là một người một người kiểu
sinh ô đi Tôi từng cũng từng phỏng vấn
rồi tôi từng phỏng vấn như cái và cũng
cũng kiểu dạng là cũng biết qua vài cải
tổ
người ta đòi hỏi yêu cầu cần gì rồi
và tôi từng đi dạy mà nếu tôi tự tin là
khoảng Tôi đánh giá một cái seri ý nghĩa
là CV của dân công nghệ thông tin là nên
có những nên có những cái tiêu chí gì
ông ngoại tôi từng dạy các bạn viết cv
rồi và bây giờ đến lúc mà các bạn sẽ
phải nên viết cv và
đương nhiên là có thể nhắn tin chắc là
tôi sẽ để một cái gì đó để mấy ông chỉ
nhắn tin được cho tôi tôi xem qua thôi
thì à
Ừ tôi sẽ chấm cho mấy ông
anh gà Thế gọi là bài tập cho mấy ông
như ra khi bài về nhà cho tôi tôi ngồi
chấm mệt với tôi vẫn còn chưa chấm trợ
được cho mấy ông về mấy cái độ đồ án Vừa
rồi tôi vẫn chưa chấm nốt được này
cho tôi chưa thời gian nói thật
bởi vì máy tính laptop kia còn năng sửa
tôi xin phép và đội khi nào máy tính kia
sửa xong để mà tôi thu hết cốt mới về
rồi tôi chấm cho mấy ông bù nha vì mấy
tôi đã máy điều quá đem đi sửa rồi à
cho nên đại khá như thế thì trước đồ ăn
hay tôi sẽ mong mà Cái quan trọng là khi
mà mày không biết siêu vị nếu không sẽ
chắc chắn là mấy ông sẽ thắc mắc rồi kìa
một ngày cần ghi gì đặc biệt là cái mục
về ở kiểu kinh nghiệm làm việc ấy đấy
mấy ông sẽ thấy kia cái CV của mình quá
sơ sài nếu mà mình không học mình không
làm cái gì đó tivi số và sơ sài kính
cùng đấy Đấy do mấy ông sẽ có thêm động
lực để mấy ông muốn làm đẹp cái seri của
máy ông
Ừ nó vậy tôi mà mày ông nhìn là cái suy
nghĩ của mình tôi thường ai Tôi hưởng
mỗi năm tôi lại viết cv lại một lần nếu
như khi có cái thói quen như thế làm bìa
đăng lên nha Facebook là ngày 5 sao mà
nhắc lại rất là hay mỗi năm nó nó lại
nhau lại tôi là năm trước tivi tôi chồng
như thế nào đấy thì ông sẽ có động lực
để mày Ông cảm thấy sau một năm Mình đã
thay đổi nơi nào đúng bọn mình thay đổi
cách viết này thay đổi cách xưng hô vân
vân và làm việc kinh nghiệm nữa Nó sẽ
thay đổi hết những cái đấy
Cả ngày hôm trước giờ buổi đầu hơn 200
hôm nay năm ấy
nhưng thương sao Ờ tôi mong tất cả trà
sữa đây 50 người 50 người cùng theo mà
50 đều đều ổn thì thì thế rất ngon đấy
là sự mỗi ông Lương nghìn đô thì 50 nhân
nghìn đô 50.000 đô la Midu là
có bao nhiêu nhỉ 5000 đô đã là một trăm
Trời ơi 50.000 đô nghĩa là 1 tỉ rồi bé
nghĩa kênh của tôi đã có kiếm được tin à
của tôi kiểu kiện góp số tiền lương gặp
lại tỉ đúng không Thế là ổn
a1000 đâu ở mức lương cơ bản không phải
là cao nhé á
cái tôi tôi lỡ không để cái cái discord
mày ở dưới phần mô tả ở đó ăn một Bởi vì
lúc đầu tôi định để tôi có để ở phần
bình luận gì gió hồi mà làm Bởi tôi muốn
mục tiêu cái Server này lúc đầu chỉ để
các bạn làm đồ án thôi Ừ nếu mà ba tôi
nghĩ ở hướng đến để các bạn tâm sự giao
lưu về cả học tập nữa nên trao Tôi sẽ để
bắt đầu bây giờ tôi mới để ở phần mô tả
đoán một thì gà Các bạn có cái gì ra
lương mấy đâu tiếp theo
đồ án ra từng nói cái này đi giao trước
rồi nhưng mà chắc là bởi vì hôm trước và
mới thông báo lại trên dư tim con tin là
rất nhiều người mới vào nên thành ra tôi
cũng sẽ nhắc lại về cái vụ này Ờ lại
Thái thì tôi có băng nguyên rồi
Nó là kiểu mình sẽ học mới
cap6 đó mới xây cái Open Facebook Ừ thì
thì cái mà tôi đang định nói
đập à Đúng rồi sau đó nữa là mình sẽ làm
một cái đồ án và cái đồ ăn Đấy nó sẽ
thì nó sẽ từ mức độ dễ cho đến khó tôi
sẽ tôi sẽ cố dậy theo kiểu dạng như thế
nào tôi sẽ dậy bởi vì leo nó có cái
em có cái chở nâng cao hỗ trợ mình hết
rồi cốt có thể rất nhàm nhưng tôi vẫn sẽ
dạy các bạn từ cái kiểu do các bạn sẽ
biết rồi Nói chung là tôi sẽ khi mà dậy
và Eriol tôi sẽ nói qua về cái vụ đấy
các bạn kỹ hơn họ sẽ hiểu hơn về dạy các
bạn 3 cách cốt cơ và cách cốt một cái
cốt của nông dân kiểu dạng là thuần hết
thể áp dụng Facebook cho mình chơi thuần
thì không Mình không chơi hàng của nó
một cái là quay bị đơ xong rồi một cái
nữa là dùng hàm của nó đấy thì tôi sẽ
dạy theo kiểu thế để sao cho mà các bạn
về sau đi làm không phải là mỗi không
phải làm
không phải là mỗi vào leo các bạn làm
bất kỳ Facebook khác thì các bạn cũng
vẫn nhớ vẫn nhớ về cách làm cũng như là
nhớ câu câu em chứ không phải là kiểu
các bạn chỉ biết mỗi level thôi công ty
và tuyển tuyển cái khác em không làm em
bỏ đấy 02 Ừ nhưng mà tôi vẫn hướng đến
cho mấy ông mà b'lao bây giờ rất nhiều
công ty tuyển thực sự nếu mà vào được
công ty làm level thì mình có sẵn nên
thôi mình làm chân IO thẳng luôn sieu
thẳng luôn thì nó ngon Đỡ phải mất công
học lại các thử thứ nữa
tiếp theo của bạn hỏi tôi về Black in
pace tôm thì đưa tôi tiện thì chia sẻ
luôn nhỉ Tôi sẽ mở đây Lucky nó ạ
này dài vãi I
ờ ờ đầu tiên thì nv fide support rồi mà
đọc được file nv này
cái này Vì sao các bạn sẽ hiểu file về
bên nào anh này kệ x lo này là để mà
Ừ để làm cái gì trong đó có thích nó là
tôi chỉ nhớ Thế không rõ nó tác dụng làm
gì được
Anh Tiến ơi Cái này ngon vãi Hồi đấy tôi
tôi cài background
tôi chọn thư mục ảnh gái xinh của tôi đè
những cái này không còn tôi để một là 10
ví dụ 10 giây đổi ảnh nên một lần thì da
kiểu thể thao mát lắm hoặc là tôi sẽ làm
cái có cái phím tắt và cũng không cần
bấm phím tắt đấy lại đội ảnh thì ra nó
đỡ đau mắt hơn nhưng mà về sau thì đúng
nó vẫn nó vẫn đau mắt màu mẹ quá không
được chung có được để tôi tạo bắt nó bị
thấy cả bọn nào lại một cái rất hay này
đây tôi đôi khi trở về sau tôi sẽ chia
sẻ cho ông rất nhiều cái cốt đoạn cốt mà
nó rất là hay ngắn gọn súc tích và trong
trong cái nền đẹp mặt chất là nó sẽ dựa
trên cái nền của cái trang này Trang
carbon nào này thì thì cái này rất là
hay ở điểm và ba tôi sẽ thể Đây chắc là
vẫn là ví dụ mày không nhỉ a tóm tắt này
nhé copy cả Tôi bôi này không ấy mà
khi
tôi ấn rồi thuộc quyền sử phải ấn phím
thì được gì
đâu tông dùng
thôi cài đấy nhưng mà lại lâu rồi tôi
không được Có dịch dùng nên thành ra nó
hơi quên hết rồi à
À đúng rồi tôi chưa tạo cái à keyboard
cho Cup cho nó bỏ xa tôi sẽ để là con
trống ship C
à mà không Tôi bị dính ơi ở khó nhỉ
đẩy cốt xăng bên trang này
em heo have seen tôi có Snap cốt Tôi
dùng cái Snap cốt chứ tôi không dùng cái
carbon An này mấy nữa nhưng mà gửi các
món ăn này có giao diện trong đẹp còn
nếu mà kiểu copy của smartphone này thì
tôi là có phím này rồi à
Ê cái code screenshot này cho tôi sẽ hết
nó ra đâu nhỉ
cho tôi cho một cái tên đây
đó nó sẽ ra như này
khi nó thức a nó sẽ đúng nền của mình
nên là nó không hẳn là đẹp lắm nhưng mà
đúng à và bôi bôi đen sao mà làm như thế
về cơ bản nó vẫn có tiện một phần nào
đấy Nếu thấy đúng ạ Đấy con cái thằng Cò
thằng carbon nào thì nhảy sang ngay cho
đẹp số tôi thể export ra kiểu dạng hả
export dạng chỗ ở
nghe Tải download Panel để mà kiểu gửi
cho mấy ông hoặc băng lên đăng lên kiểu
làm mẹo vặt cho mấy ông giữa hai về sau
tôi có rất nhiều ảnh mẹ gặp theo tôi sẽ
cho mày không xem tiếp theo
bước ai nữa nhỉ Hôm nay khi được điện
anh ngày kia giới thiệu cấu hình khi sử
thời gian
về các bạn thì hôm nay thời ra kiến thức
nó khó đấy ngoài dễ đâu ngày hôm nay bữa
hôm nay dai hơn hội hôm trước chắc chắn
hôm trước hôm trước có một tiếng rồi anh
nhỉ À ờ cốt screenshot là cái các bạn
với thấy rồi this tool post này là một
cái cũng là
à à
có một cái cũng hay ông đừng có gạo tôi
với cốt nữa ông không thay đổi được ý
kiến vừa rồi ghi toolbox này nó có cái
hay ở đây đó là ngoài việc là nó tự động
kiểu faq nghĩa tự động kéo Cốt về để mà
cậu đề mà bất cốt vào thì thì nó còn có
khả hiển thị ra là rít lên Tức ám chỉ
nếu dịch thu kiểu đổ lỗi cho thằng nào
chả thế cái ruộng là chỉ ở đây này chỉ ở
đây Các bạn thấy là người cốt cuối cùng
cốc cái dòng này để mà đăng lên chính là
chị em chửi đó Cứ thế giờ hai tôi rất
nhiều lúc tôi chỉ vào để biết được ông
nào nó không cốc cái đoạn trong vãi
chưởng nhé
tiếp theo nhỉ
Ờ Ờ
cái này Ừ cái này để cho Sport để ở Ừ
thì nhớ cái tôi không dùng
anh bỏ đi
chơi cái này để highlight cho cái
à mà
breakfast tất cả Em chỉ là cái vòng mặc
Ngọ mẹo Khéo chọn ấn vào dòng cái chỗ
nào ngọn thì nó sẽ luôn kiểu kiểu thông
báo ở bên bên ai này để biết được vào
dòng nhọn nhọn đây xem Thấy tiện đúng
này leo này cái này để hỗ trợ cậu nó nó
gợi ý các hàm vào đây là Real này cái
này cũng để gợi ý Hàn Model Nhưng mà
theo dạng quay Vy cái này hợp để mà nếu
mà các bạn cài thêm có thêm cái bản chất
thằng Iran là ngon hơn phòng vé cốt ở
điểm đó là nó có thể kết nối ra tao bây
luôn ở trong cái ID này Thế em đi do nó
rất nặng nhưng mà chính vì như thế nào
khi các bạn kết nối xong đấy các bạn kết
hợp với Lazio quay này xong là nó sẽ đề
xuất ra như này theo các bạn là tên tên
cột tên Tara
cho ví dụ ở nó thông nó gợi ý trong lúc
cốt là kiểu tên Cột nào như này Nếu phải
không Nếu thấy ra đây không tên bảng tên
cột như này rồi lúc cốt Nói chung là nó
gợi ý ngon lắm Nói cho tôi làm theo
thằng này mấy ông sẽ thấy rất nhiều lúc
rồi tôi hiểu mấy gõ nửa cái tên biến rồi
nó gợi ý cả đến biến rồi trèo nó kêu anh
hiển thị ra có thể thử rất là tiện
cái này
premium À
cái này để mà làm giao diện của tôi hiện
tại mấy ông mới cài mặc định giao diện
nó xấu hơn cái của tôi tiếp theo là cái
này là để bôi à khi mà ông chọn vào một
cái gì đó ví dụ đặc biệt ở bên biến nó
sẽ kiểu hiển thị ra kiểu dạng làm màu
màu của cái tên biến đấy
ở chỗ là cái này phải ví dụ mới được
cái không phải màu đấy
xe cày mặt bị giờ của thằng thằng có rồi
không nhớ lắm rõ ràng là thằng này chuẩn
là nó phải kiểu hiển thị ra rõ phân biệt
màu vậy đều để bỏ cái này một cái rất là
ngon này cái này để nó sẽ cảnh báo cho
ông những cái đoạn nào về đây hiệu năng
này xong ngồi những cái những cái ý keo
có vấn đề này hay gì đó nó gợi ý rất
nhiều nhưng quan cả bảo mật này cái ông
Linh cài cái này để nó đọc được cốt của
ông đương nhiên nhiều lúc nó vẫn đọc hơi
tệ tí phải vì nó không hẳn chuyên nghiệp
ví dụ Giả sử đây nó kiệm nó có thể thông
báo cho biển này không tồn tại A biến
này không đúng rồi biến 201 Tại tự nhiên
khai báo đây đúng không Nghĩa Thực ra nó
không nó không biết được là mình in Plus
cái file biến này từ chỗ khác nhưng mà
rõ ràng ở nó đọc nó chỉ đọc được trong
file thôi Thế nên thành ra nó kiểu cảnh
báo biến hay không tồn tại đây Ừ cái Tab
nay này làm một cái kiểu như tôi bảo một
cái ai vậy mà đây nó bảo là để mà để mà
kiểu hỗ trợ các bạn kiểu gõ Cốt nó nhanh
hơn ngàn hơn top cái này nó cũng giống
cái của thằng là
của thằng get hấp Nó cốt pha lót nhưng
mà thằng này nó sinh ra trước mà tôi tôi
vẫn đang thích chẳng ai hơn có Vios rồi
tôi chưa dù có cái lợi và cái này hiện
tại tôi đang dùng là tôi không nhớ là
mất phí miễn phí nữa hình nhờ Thì nhờ
mất phí rồi vì ông anh Tôi gửi tôi cái
kia cùng chung à
à còn còn nếu mạ miễn phí nhà nó nó giới
hạn thêm vài cái đấy nhưng mà cũng ngon
nó gọi cái ảnh để mà đọc cả cái bô Rách
của ông để gợi ý ngon phết trưng phải là
kiểu gợi ý cơ bản của thằng i i
bầu cua cá tham để đo xem nào tôi ngồi
cốt bao nhiêu tiếng
cái này không biết là cái gì
Ford Vinh
anh khóc bỏ
nhiên nó mở lại như vậy Cái này để kết
nối em đã tao Kris rồi
32 chỗ nào Cái này cứ tặng để đấy thì
nhớ liên quan tâm bên này có rất nhiều
cái đây tôi tắt bớt đi mấy ông mới cài
đôi khi nó mở hết lên đấy
nha như cái code Vaio thì tôi biết được
nó Cốt lại gõ tên hàm nó hiển thị luôn
cả một đoạn có dài đúng không anh cái
tình sau
Ừ cái này có thể chỉ để mà hình như để
mạnh liên quan về xếp tinh gì Gì này này
là kệ này rất nhiều cái đây tôi không
dùng tôi tắt hết đi này mà em không dùng
cái nào tắt bữa đi ở sẽ nhẹ bớt không ạ
Cái này viết được cái Mắc daoud tội
chẳng dùng mấy này
ở dưới này thì ra là toàn mấy cái không
không quan trọng nữa mình cái kỳ quan
trọng thôi
Ừ đúng nhà tay còn cỗ vị đấy mình cái
trên là quan trọng thôi mình cái dưới
tôi thấy đọc được có vẻ cái nôi nên tớ
đánh dấu tích vào quyển sư mất là cái
đấy gì ở ở
ý của tôi cài ít
ờ ờ tôi cũng đọc qua khá nhiều plugin
rồi nhưng mà tôi cũng chỉ giới hạn Cài
thế không biết được bây giờ nó thêm
login nhiều nữa không Okay tiếp
a tiếp theo là thật sự thì pp nó không
chuyên sâu Mở v xe và Oppa bằng ra pha
nên thành ra là
nếu có thể mấy ông biết trước Java chợ
hoa cài mái ông kiểu xích học chuyên về
mới shopee thì tôi khuyên với ông đi học
về bên Java họ thậm chí
như thế hơn là học TP nói chuyện với mới
cũng như là tôi sẽ dạy cho mấy ông mới
xe và ok ở mức cơ bản mà tôi biết rồi
Tôi nhảy sang Lara chứ không phải là tôi
dậy chuyên sau trông hẳn về hai cái này
nên là mấy ông mà đang bị hỏng phải mở
shopee mà mày ông Nghĩa học của tôi là
đủ rồi thì chuyến áp đâu nha Nhưng mà
không phải là kiến thức của tôi dậy thế
thì không làm được gì Bởi vì
Ừ thì ông thấy tôi đang đi làm đây rồi
đúng không Nghĩa lắm chị ạ Không phải
tôi cốt kẻo nữa nhé khẳng định ở cốt của
tôi vừa
tốt của tôi dùng 10 năm nữa vẫn cũng
được khác với cái hồi tôi đi dậy đúng ở
hội đấy tôi tự học tự cốt kém thật nhưng
bây giờ tôi va chạm thôi và tôi cũng
biết qua nói chung là tội biết tôi yêu
mấy cái này rồi nghe tôi bây giờ cốt Ok
đó là mới xe ổn rồi nhưng tôi khẳng định
được kiến thức của tôi dậy là đủ là đủ
để mà các bạn đi làm
tôi vẫn sẽ theo cái
cày chí hướng như thế nghĩa là chỉ cần
đủ cho bạn đi làm được không cần nói gì
áo kiểu cực kì kiểu gắp ok
a tiếp theo là
thực là chị hôm nay thật giờ tôi không
biết là hôm nay tôi đang thiếu ngủ nên
hơi gắt thì phải con biết nhưng mà
em
lấy địa chỉ đi thấy
trả lời nói này đã
ở
đó làm Nếu mấy ông mà có thắc mắc gì thì
mới ông có thể nhắn tin hỏi tôi tâm sự
cũng được nhưng mà Mấy ông oa hạn chế
hỏi tôi mấy câu mà mấy ông kia phải dùng
thử nhà
tốt nhất là đưa ngờ cho sẵn không ai
thích các bạn cho hỏi hỏi đố thêm Cậu
hỏi hỏi
anh hỏi vặn vẹo mình kiểm tra kiến thức
của dạng là nếu sử các bạn mà thấy có là
cực kỳ khó các bạn muốn thử thử cậu ấy
các bạn hỏi nhắn tin nhiều lúc tôi sẽ
không trả lời đâu thì tôi về các bạn tôi
khá bận với ông cậu và cái thứ hai đó là
đã có nhiều câu sao mà ông hoặc là nhiều
câu mà chẳng ai hỏi
anh nói nha béo hỏi
có bao nhiêu nhỉ nói như nào nhỉ giống
như kiểu có ông ấy từng hỏi tôi là cả
Tại sao mày tính hoạt động
đi học chứ tại sao nó dùng hàng này nó
viết hàm tên như thế này không phải tên
kia có nhiều câu cửa Tôi không biết được
nên chả được mình cái coi như nào ạ
ờ ờ ngớ ngẩn thì tôi tôi tôi khó mà ở
Diễn tả đây này lắm bởi phải có nhiều
câu mà Mấy ông Nghĩa là ngớ ngẩn Nhưng
mà thực ra đấy các câu hay tôi đã từng
thấy rất nhiều sinh viên tôi hỏi rất
nhiều câu rất là hay mà tôi thực ra tôi
quên mất để tôi nói với ông tôi quên hẳn
luôn đấy mẹ để nói mấy ông đã từng rất
nhiều bạn inbox thôi câu hỏi hay tôi có
tôi có lưu lại để mà tôi sẽ chia sẻ với
ông rồi
nghe tôi không thể nào bảo mấy ông đừng
có hỏi thì thế không hay sao chẳng là
mấy ông nên hỏi nhưng mà
Ê mấy ông cũng phải hơi bị lọc cô họ
được đi
chắc là tôi sẽ có một vài ví dụ sau
Nhưng nhưng mà ví dụ hôm nay có một bạn
có hỏi ôm một câu xa Đại lấy đề bài từ
đâu đấy từ một trang nào đó ấy
nhà hàng Hà tội Tôi cảm thấy kiểu cái đề
bài nó khá khá là linh tinh ý
cho tôi câu kiểu cảm thấy không muốn trả
lời cho tôi lắm và đặc biệt là có liên
quan của khách cùng nữa tôi cả không
muốn trả lời đấy kiện như thế à
rút kinh nghiệm cho các bạn gì hay không
ngờ tôi thì cách giải bài thôi
Ừ Ok
Thôi giải giảm quá của mày sẽ đi hẳn bây
giờ sẽ vào tiết mục trình đi hôm nay
mình sẽ học mới xây Oppa ah nhầm MBC và
kết hợp với xe cruzee QD là gì nó đó là
last update Delete Đúng không ạ
bí quyết viết lại tự nhiên quên rồi
xe CRV được ạ
address
list update và Delete ngoại
đó là thêm xem sửa xóa ngọn thêm trước
phải có cái nhìn trước nóng ạ nhưng bây
giờ một cái ví dụ đơn giản nhất là bây
giờ Tôi muốn vào trang web Quét các bạn
không ạ
nâng cao trong tết này
em ở nhà khi mà tôi vào cái trang này
tôi bây giờ không cần không làm như cái
hôm trước rồi chúng ta đi nhà hàng nữa
mà tôi muốn là kiểu làm trang web để
quản lý sinh viên em ạ thì tất cả khi
nhà mới vào trang web thì sẽ nhìn toàn
bộ sinh viên và có thể nút có thể nút
bấm thêm sinh viên mới và sửa sinh viên
cũ hoặc là sinh viên cũ đấy Cơ bản là
như thế sẽ rủ rê không ạ thì mình làm
theo mô hình mvc thì sẽ làm như thế nào
thì tôi sẽ thử nói cho các bạn đầu tiên
tôi có Xóa hết toàn bộ nó ngoài đi rồi
ông ạ
bây giờ vậy tại sao không có gì cả đúng
ạ mặc định nó sẽ cầu hình thì cây chung
mục như thế này nhưng mà không có gì cả
thì cái đầu tiên các bạn vẫn còn nhớ là
chúng ta sẽ ở luôn tạo file Index ngoạn
thời tạo phanh đĩa trước
và
Pha này thời cá nó vẫn chị luôn có cái
đơn giản như này nó mình sẽ luôn gọi đến
controller ngoài controller
khi cài file con trơn này nơ này chắc
chắn chưa tồn tại đúng không Mình sẽ tạo
phải này
à à
sẽ luôn chỉ có chỉ có bếp cốt PT thôi
tiếp theo đầu tiên thì các bạn ấy đưa nó
trang trắng tinh không hiển thị cái này
nữa bởi vì sao vì lúc đầu nó vào file
crack for further gọi phải controller
wi-fi con chơi đang chẳng đúng không
tiếp theo thì mình cần ở đây đó là mình
cần hiển thị toàn bộ danh sách của sinh
viên đi Chẳng hạn tất làm chị ở sao Tức
là controller này nó sẽ gọi đến cái
thằng mua đồ sờ phỏng các bạn nhờ cái
ảnh không ạ về chắc mình cứ phải cho các
bạn xem là cái ảnh nó dễ hình dung ảnh
như tôi còn lễ hội trên desktop này phải
Có ai đổi
Ừ Ừ
đợi tôi một tí nhé
từ hôm trước tình yêu tôi có tại ở đây
đấy
pro.io Tôi đang gửi ảnh lại lời nói ông
trên mạng nhé
Lúc đầu vào mình nách này đấy anh gọi
con lô này sau đó thì controller bây giờ
sẽ gọi mua đồ để mua đồ lấy trong
database sẽ lời ra sinh viên sau đó đi
thằng thằng này nó sẽ lấy cái thông tin
của mua đồ đã đã xử lý sau đó đi trả về
nằm trong cái view kém nên thông tin
sinh viên không ạ Thì bây giờ mình sẽ
làm như sao thì thằng này còn gọi đến
thằng
mua đồ chơi Popin này
nha à
chị sẽ tạo file mua đồ thôi
cái này cũng chỉ pp thôi đoạn này mình
sẽ có kết nối cơ sở dữ liệu đúng không
vẫn là điều khúc con ếch này mai có con
ếch nó có hót root
xe
tải như này
hôm trước là ghi Chu school thì cả
Thì ra tôi xóa hết đã bây giờ này chắc
bây giờ tôi sẽ phải
đã kết nối lại là tao bay nữa
Ừ đợi tí nhé tôi tạo lại cái đã tới bây
I
Ừ tôi sẽ à bé Giêsu school này à
to school
anh như này
a cho tôi sẽ sửa lại cái này một tí
ở những chỗ school I
ở set này Open đỏ
con knack này đi
bây giờ mình sẽ tạo bạc thì sẽ Express
phê bồ sinh viên này
sẽ có mã PIN auto-increment
tane
sau đó icry Monkey mã chẳng hạn
Ờ
Ờ mình có thể thêm những thông tin khác
nhưng cái cơ bản thôi cứ dậy các bạn như
này trước đã
bạn dùng Perman nữa vì thực hơn cái thế
rất là giờ cậu cơ bản và nó không hẳn là
xịn lắm nữa ở công ty thường người ta sẽ
dùng rất nhiều cái công cụ xịn khác cũng
cụ mình đang dùng cũng không ăn công cụ
xịn nhất nhưng về cơ bản nó miễn phí và
nó cũng dễ cài còn rất nhiều phần mềm
khác thì phải
các bạn sẽ phải crack hay gì gì đó có
rất nhiều cá ngon mà cũng trước mình
tương dùng giống như fg off có chữ mình
rất thích mình tí nha mình phá thì dùng
cái đấy nhất chỗ này
anh em phải crack mà mỗi khi mà mới ông
phải mới cài crack về mấy ông dễ bị dính
virus hay gì cả
cái có biểu tượng con hẹn cá heo này cái
này nó hỗ trợ việc là các bạn cứ chọn
chọn mấy cái bảng xong mà nó sẽ hiển thị
ra câu truy vấn ngon vết ví dụ Giả sử
này các bạn chọn chọn bà này nó sẽ hiển
thị ra câu truy vấn nha các bạn sẽ copy
coi chị vấn đề mà chạy các bạn chỉ cần
nối Nối ngay Rất tiện
cho tôi biết tôi thì nhiều tội biết được
có phần mềm khác làm cái tương tự như
này hồi đầu tôi dùng cái này xuống Chích
cái này
còn cái này thì nó không hỗ trợ với đây
hơi tệ mà tôi không biết trả đâu
a-team tạo bảng chưa này đúng không ạ
Ừ
cái này các bạn sao Google rồi các bạn
tự cài được tự trải nghiệm thôi
chào
các bạn Tôi khuyên ở mấy ông cũng lên
kiểu bây giờ ờ trải nghiệm dần chứ không
cần nghe hoàn toàn tôi nói gì đâu không
à
Ừ chắc gì thầy đã biết ngon
Wow này là sự snacks
sao from sinh viên đúng không làm cho
sinh viên gì cả
mấy ông thể dùng cái này như tự nói dùng
cái tay Kết nối nên cái thằng này là cái
nồi ra ngày thì nó sẽ luôn để đề xuất
tên cột cho bé uống rất là ngon Bây giờ
tôi chưa làm vụ đấy vội hay là bộ luôn
cho mình xem nhé thử nhé Nó chỉ nó đơn
giản của này chị chọn mai que o này
ạ sau đây Alo Có hot
bây giờ rút đúng không
cài đặt tài bay ở dưới you scored này
thế này cho nhanh rồi
anh alo mày Ông còn Thaco lấy chuẩn nếu
thành công cho mèo offline được
thế này ok rồi đó
tại sao thông báo đây luôn
không mà chẳng gọi gì cả thời tiếp ngờ
về sau vì sao nó sẽ gợi ý khi bật các
bạn sang bên em nó với Mon Cực
em yên tâm với vụ này
kết quả trở về bằng Mafia
các thứ tiện lại đây Nói chung trả lời
hết kết quả đây không ạ
sau đó thì mình sẽ gọi cái gì nữa mình
sẽ gọi đến cái thằng một hòm view Nhưng
quan trọng là hôm nay mình làm à
thì mình sẽ làm xe rủ rê nên mình sẽ có
view có tận 4 cái view ở đâu có ba cái
view ít nhất là 3 view một cái là mưu để
mà xem phòng thêm này một một một cái
Hiển thị danh sách toàn bộ sinh viên này
Kris không ạ một cái video để hiển thị
update là đúng ạ nên
không ạ Tại ít nhất là chúng ta sẽ ba
view nên tôi cách tôi làm thì tôi sẽ là
tạo một thư mục tên là view như thế này
sau đó đi tôi sẽ tạo file trong này file
này file mặc định thường là mê tên cũng
là tên fake cũng được cũng được thường
là sẽ như thế hiểu là file này file đây
mà xem tất cả phải xem danh sách
lại như này
Ê mày sẽ lấy ntech-i
khi mở file này Bây giờ tôi thể h1o Nghe
danh sách sinh viên ạ à
à nhầm nhầm nhầm suýt chết đấy nó đang
chạy vòng lắm phải view rồi đấy mình
đúng chứ không phải đã này nó nó vừa ý
có nốt lại Trịnh chính là ngày này anh
cũng nốt thằng này vòng lặp mua thận mất
để quy hiểu à
Ừ ok đây Hiển thị danh sách sinh viên
nhưng mà mếu thấy ở đây thì có không
đúng chơi thì đi ra sẽ làm gì có sinh
viên nào này cũng chẳng còn gì cả đúng
không Bây giờ mình sẽ có cái bảng đây
nhưng mỗi khi nè Thấy hát này ở đây sẽ
ra mã này
Tên này á
anh ở đây sẽ vòng reflect này khó chịu
này phết Cái gợi ý nó không ngon lắm
Mấy cái vụ công mặc và tôi không nhớ
cách viết ở trong cái này lắm
mấy ông cách để tạo phím tắt này cái
vòng mấy cái trong này nó gọi là
template là Blake cái gì đó của trong
phòng pantone này chúng em sẽ kiện hơn à
a
nói là Blade gì gói
Ừ
cái này có khi nó cột Tôi muốn nhảy sáng
tệ là sắp itecco cái đoạn này rồi Copy
lại vì sao mới tách nó hỗ trợ về thông
minh hơn
ok Nói chung ạ nhưng mà yên tâm về sau
tôi sẽ khi mà dậy xong razzil thì tôi
không dùng pp Bình thường tôi sẽ dùng
Brad và thằng này lại hỗ trợ gõ Plus
ngon phết Tôi vẫn chấp nhận dùng cái này
dạy các bạn
thì tại sao đến bây giờ không có cái gì
không học sinh viên gì cả Không ạ ạ
vẫn chưa có sinh viên rồi cả Mẹ là tôi
thử xem một sinh viên mới để em không
xem nhé sự năm ạ ạ
ở
đó thì xảy ra đúng không Không thấy sẽ
chiều dạng là bây giờ Xem tổng hậu lại
toàn bộ file mình đã làm nhé Còn tiền
Index này sẽ gọi còn treo lơ đấy cũng
cho l sẽ gọi Mua đồ xong rồi để thắng
mua đồ nó làm việc kết nối cơ sở liệu
đúng không để lấy ra cái gì đó Sao nó sẽ
tham mưu đồ thì bản chất là nó sẽ cái
nồi Cơ sở lý hiệu sau đó thì lấy thông
tin nó thôi đúng không nó trả về kết quả
vào trong này rồi từ kết quả này mình sẽ
truyền vào trong cái view Index này và
bây giờ mình hiển thị ra đúng không Các
bạn thấy à Hồi trước mình sẽ nộp hết
toàn bộ cái này vào trong một file vừa
sẽ tách nhỏ và file như thế này đúng
không Ok Thế bây giờ mới chỉ là bước
bước cơ bản giống như hôm trước mình làm
đó là bấm vào thì chị ra còn bây giờ
mình làm tính năng thêm một vài cái nữa
thì ra Ví dụ rồi truyền trên Ví dụ mình
bấm vào đây thêm một sinh viên mới ra
sao thì nó sẽ cân Hiển thị như nào cái
file crack này tôi sẽ tắt ạ Bây giờ mình
sẽ không gần nhiều không lao động phải
đấy đấy nữa tiếp theo con solo Thì bây
giờ mình sẽ phải xử lý trong trường hợp
nếu là sự bây giờ tôi sẽ có thể một thẻ
ở đây chẳng ạ Có thể a đây bị sẽ là thêm
sinh viên này
nhà mình sẽ có hollis
bằng cái gì đó về khi bấm vào sẽ hiểu là
thêm sinh viên gì đó nó vui Gọi cái gì
nha
nó vừa gọi một cái gì đó đúng không đi
thắp liệu sẵn ờ
truyền lên một cái J quét Mở yêu cầu
nhưng mà tôi thừa anh gọi nói 1 action
là một hành động sẽ gọi tôi sẽ hỏi chấm
nha trên bằng à a great với cả thêm ngon
đây tôi sẽ hiểu là bấm Bấm vào các bạn
có thể
các bạn thể dùng Arsenal là insaat
cũng được nhưng mà tôi sẽ dùng từ khái
niệm Brad vì bắt chước là Leo vào leo vì
sợ sự phân biệt à led này xong rồi cái
gì đó nữa vì sao tôi dậy kiu ngoài mày
khái niệm ma trận của thằng lao theo quy
ước để tránh việc Nói chung nó từ khóa
vào quy ước là quy chuẩn như thế chứ mấy
ông đặt tên là a b c nó cũng được nhưng
chẳng ai đã không không không ai nên đặt
ở A B C không ạ
Gửi cho thầy tôi dạy ABC thật đấy à là
gì bây giờ thì sẽ hiển thị cho dễ như
không Tôi sẽ dạy mày Ok chậm hẳn luôn
như thế này để mà khi của các à rất là
dễ ok chưa Đấy bây giờ bấm vào thì bây
giờ đã lẽ chuẩn phải Thiện form để làm
thêm sinh viên chức phải Hiển thị danh
sách này không ạ thì Tức là bên
controller này mình sẽ kiểm tra điều
kiện đó là kiểu mình sẽ lấy á trên về
nóng lạnh cách Hôm trước mình làm đó là
ít nếu mà kiểu Nếu mà trống cái đôla get
a xinh thế này nghĩa nếu mà không quá
Chân thì mình sẽ trả về ở đây con eo
mình sẽ trả về như thế nào đấy ông ạ
nhưng mà tôi không thích kiểu ngay bởi
vì tí mình sẽ có khá nhiều ai xin nghe
Tôi sẽ dùng with key để mà làm này mà
tôi từ từ Uyên nói đúng kiểu như này cho
mấy ông tôi sẽ có khái niệm đầu tiên là
tôi cái mặc định có xóa trên là chấm và
tôi Thỉnh thoảng thôi không nhắc lại
bụng trông gì à
Xong rồi nếu mất kiểm tra nếu có tồn tại
thì tôi lại cho trên sẽ bằng cái đôla
ghét Trần này như thế này
sau đó thì ở đây tôi sẽ xích cay I
anh sex phá trinh
Ừ tôi làm chỉ nó vẫn chấm như này thì
mình sẽ đi quay nha subject như thế này
Ê
mèo tôi thử vào đại tràng lúc đầu này FA
cháo gì thay đổi cả nhiều tôi bấm vào
đây nó đã không nhảy vào cái trường hợp
này bởi cây trong trường hợp này Arsenal
sẽ bằng LED rồi thì mình sẽ Express a
mình sẽ cây quét ở đây ạ
chị đã sửa đây Alo một thì mấy ông sẽ
thấy đúng không nó sẽ chị ở số 1 Tức là
nó nhiều vào đây nó không để lại nữa
không ạ Mày không có thể cho luôn một
cái đi photo tôi nhá Để phong như thế
này và mình sẽ rô là
nhập hai chân linh tinh gì thế thằng ạ
Cái này ngoài việc kiểu hiển thị ra cho
vui như thế này cũng để cảnh báo người
dùng Nếu có người dùng kiểu truyền lên
một gái xứng không hợp lệ này cái gì hết
đến nhà mình có Black đây đúng không
cái Bởi vì nếu trượt do xưởng người dùng
nhập ta sẽ chúng ta Tây Nguyên này thì
sai đúng không ạ Đấy à
mình hiểu là mình sẽ chuyện mình sẽ nhảy
vào đây làm việc đúng ạ thì khi mà mình
thêm mới một sinh viên thì mình hiển thị
ra form thêm thôi chứ Mình chưa có động
vào cơ sở liệu vội Đông ạ Mình sẽ copy
cái đoạn này đổi đây là crash là được
tôi sẽ tạo file này và này nó phải crash
chuẩn TP à
không mở thẻ HTML thôi Thứ bởi vì sao
tới dạy mày ông về đèn mà
chen kiểu một hàng có thể in Plus Hoàng
kia các từ thứ Nếu tôi sẽ dạy mày ông
chị cái thằng ở giữa rồi tôi dậy ông bỏ
đi rồi còn toàn bộ những cái phần thằng
kia dạng máy new phần thân về sau tôi
hướng dẫn mấy ông nhanh sau thế tôi chỉ
dạy mấy ông ấy em ấy Cái ở giữa thôi
á hả Nó dậy là đeo đâu mà cậu biết à
Anh tên này trên phút này hai tac đúng
không ạ rất là đơn giản nên là tên về
sau tôi buồn Hôm nay tôi tiếng Việt dàn
dần những buổi sau tôi dậy mấy ông Toàn
bộ chứng anh ấy nghĩa là à không phải
toàn bộ câu không nói tiếng Anh nhưng mà
ý tên biến này xong rồi à tên
Anh tên tên biến này đổi tên cột trên
bảng Tôi sẽ để hết tiếng Anh à
ạ
à Nó đây là sử thêm Bphone
ở
ạ thi ở đây for của mình khi bấm thêm
cho vui như thế này thì các bạn thấy là
nó truyền dạng như này là sai bởi vì sao
Bởi nó chẳng có một cái áo xinh đi kèm
Và thậm chí for này không phải mới thấy
là pop con không phải mấy hớp là post
thì càng xa thì các bạn phải luôn để
mình cái mới thoát hiểm trừ khi ở shop
shop thì các bạn mình nên để là dạng
ghét thôi còn đâu gần như chủ yếu sẽ
support này các bạn sẽ luôn quá trình là
Cho
hỏi chấm này hả Trần Bằng
ạ bây giờ xin của tôi sẽ ra store như
thế này không phải Insert đâu nó store
bởi theo leo nó như thế tiếp theo là mấy
thớt nhập pass như này còn nếu mà ông
không để mới hơn như thế này nó sẽ ghi
đè nát chân này Tôi ví dụ mà ông nhá Ừ
chả lên không ạ Còn nếu là mấy thôi lập
phốt thì nó sẽ không bị đi đây
cho iPhone đó như thế này trong trường
hợp này thì đương nhiên nó bảo là mình
chưa khai báo rẽ chuyện đấy rồi mình sẽ
báo đây Các bạn thấy là tui tạo nhiều
pha nhỏ như thế nhưng mình sửa mọi thứ
đấy rất là nhanh rất là dễ em mình sẽ
cho các bạn đây là to này để lưu lại này
Đợt này mình sẽ gọi đến thằng này thôi
mình không gọi view gì cả trong trường
hợp này Mình lại sửa tiếp mình sẽ copy
cái này copy cái này sang cái này và
mình sẽ lại copy cái này vào trong
trường hợp này làm chị ở Xem tất cả này
đúng không
a crash xóa đi này để pho xóa đi à Vậy á
chân trong trường hợp này mình sẽ chỉ có
1 là rỗng để mà lấy toàn bộ thông tin về
Hay là để hay là kiểu lưu lại thông tin
thôi đấy như này rất là nhanh rất tiện
anh ở đây có một cái nhá đó là
hỏi hỏi hỏi lại câu hỏi nhanh nhà ở
có thằng nào là thằng nhận yêu cầu thằng
thằng control hai thằng modal là thằng
nhận yêu cầu Nếu nhớ
phẳng nhận yêu cầu
chị đã có 110 ông đang ngồi xem nhưng mà
tôi tin là quá nữa mấy ông sẽ không ở
bình luận cái gì cả
à à anh Alo ạ Alo alo
thì giờ tôi sẽ nói to như này cho mấy
ông đi ngủ alo ờ ờ thằng controller
thằng nhận yêu cầu nhân viên là nhận yêu
cầu không ạ Tức là sao nghĩa là ở trong
trường hợp này khi mình truyền lên ở
trong cái phom như thế này thì thằng
controller là thằng lấy cái biến về chứ
không phải hàng mua đồ lấy cái biển về
rồi chị ạ Mình sẽ khai báo biến ở trong
này như này tên bằng đô là
post tên như này chứ không phải thằng
mua đồ mua đồ thằng xử lý với biến nhất
Không đâu ạ thằng thằng mua đồ Chị ở
thằng làm mấy cái liên quan đến dữ liệu
rồi đấy ông ạ đời nó sẽ là gì này à
I Insert into a
cô sinh viên không ạ
mà chẳng gợi ý gì cả Chán anh
ba lô này à
lại như thế này biển tên đó thì hoàn
cảnh báo nó kệ đi Thích thì tôi tôi sẽ
tắt cái thôi kệ
và đây sẽ là
D3 tối thử chạy thử mày ông sẽ thấy nhá
không báo lỗi gì cả đúng không tại lại
đó thì chị ra Bphone rồi nó ngon thì thế
này à Xong rồi nhưng mà bây giờ mày Ông
Thực ra là là mấy ông cần điều hướng để
cho người dùng người dùng quay trở lại
cái trang này quay trở lại hiển thị xem
thêm chứ không phải là thì chị Trang
chơi những ai thiếu mình sẽ điều hướng
rồi đây anh sẽ hết đồ location ở đây
cũng được này
à à
số
đài gì này quay trở lại trang cho nó thế
sao
xe tải này mấy ông Nếu phải điều hướng
quay trở lại nhá Nếu không còn chuyện là
mấy ông vi Quay lại cái này đâu nha đã
từng có tôi thấy từ của ông đi qua là
cái này sai nhá đầy ngoạn không nói
chuyện với Quay lại cái Copy lại cái này
đây hay là cái này Go lại cái này nhá
Không mình không phải điều hướng đúng
như ai để mà Mấy ông xóa cái chân ở trên
này
vừa vô tới tại lại sang lên thì giờ nó
bị bị thành hai cái BPhone không ạ ấy
thì vừa rồi mấy ông thấy qua việc là chị
trong CRD thì nó sẽ chị khi mình thêm
một cái á chừng gì đó mình chỉ đơn giản
mình động vào file trên Zalo này xong
rồi à có thể phạm phải view tù đúng
không Sau đó mình chỉ cần thêm á chân
nữa vào trong thằng mua đồ và cốc rất là
ngắn như thế này các bạn thấy nó khi mà
thêm một cái chân gì đó cô sẽ rất là
ngắn nhớ Đây mới chỉ là một cái xe thôi
về sau nó có tối ưu là tiện hơn nhiều
nữa
Ừ ok tiếp theo nha Mình sẽ thử sửa một
cái bạn nào đó đây thì bây giờ mình động
ở bên này để mình sẽ có sửa
sửa Đông ạ
này sẽ là một hệ a a
chân là Cho hỏi trận Arsenal update
chứ không phải update nói gì nhỉ edit
ờ ờ
và mình sẽ truyền theo Mã
Ừ mình copy các bạn anh Anh
ừ ừ
edit cái và truyền mà một nó vào trong
lại quay lại với container mình sẽ lại
copy cái này mình đổi edit mình sẽ lấy
mã về
Anh mãi ở đây là dạng Ghét ông ạ
và mình sẽ cầm kết nối cơ sở liệu để mà
lấy thông tin của cái bạn có mã là một
bà truyền vào trong thằng view và view
sẽ là view t Lại đít đỏ như thế này đó
và mình sẽ Đương nhiên mình sẽ copy cái
bên này để mà
cho mình đặt 1 chân ở đây ở trên đấy đít
rồi trong trường này tôi thường ấy copy
thế này gần như là mấy ông thấy tôi copy
copy ở nhiều đấy mình sẽ có quê ở đây
này bè mã bằng đua mã này Mẹ này sẽ lấy
từ bên này lấy từ bên này đúng không ạ
bên này sẽ truyền mã sang bên này để lấy
thông tin của sinh viên có mã như thế
này sau đó kết quả trở về Nhưng mà như
tôi từng nói kết quả trả về nó sẽ luôn
là dạng mạc mà mình chỉ một lấy thang
đầu tiên thôi mình sẽ có đưa x bằng mã
ID take a ride trắng đái xong đầu tiên
ok chưa Sau đó thì mình sẽ dùng biển đâu
phải ít này ở trong cái thằng USD này
Anh thường là kệ format nó sẽ rất giống
Phong thêm không ạ đã ký kết này lên
ở Arsenal lần này tôi sẽ là update này
Bây giờ mới ăn chừng nó Tết này ờ ờ
Highlands
à à thay nạn bằng hai đình nên mạnh mã
và mình sẽ và lưu cho nó
à à
Ừ đấy Nó bắt đầu gợi ý ngon rồi đấy Mày
không thấy không Lúc đầu nó thể ra tệ
Nhưng vì sao nói gợi ý các thứ thử ngon
rồi
à Nó học mà nó sẽ học từ trong cái forex
của mấy ông
ngày xưa này
ở tại chàng đó bơ sửa bạn có tên mã một
chị sẽ Long bấm vào đây sẽ sửa iPhone
không ạ Đấy bơm yếu gì việc sữa thôi nếu
không sẽ đổi đây à nó tan tivi bung ạ
Cho em mấy ông thấy bấm sửa đấy Bây giờ
mình lại nhập thêm áp trần các thứ Mình
lại sửa ở trong container không ạ à mà
update này à
thì mình lấy mã về nhưng lần này Mã sẽ
ra giọng posts mình lấy tên về mà cũng
là dạng post
Anh tên này mình chỉ cần truyền cho mua
đồ và cũng làm tí mình sẽ điều hướng về
ngay Ngoại vẫn em điệp khúc Thế nhưng
tôi tạm tắt hết đầu đã để xem cốt lỗi
thì nó như chị ra chứ hết đồ về nó Mất
mất cái thì bị lỗi bên này mình sẽ lại à
em copy cái này tạo thêm một cái nữa
không ạ
đây sẽ là
a headache sinh viên
ở set này nó gợi ý các thử sĩ không
Vẫn khẳng định là nó bị
ở quê mã mật mã không cần trả về kết quả
gì cả đó chứ
đã sửa Ok rồi
khi chạy thử nhà ở
anh không báo lỗi gì cả về mình mới lưu
hương quay về nữa
Anh tên bằng tên qua mã bằng mã
hai a rồi phải đổ đi ăn đây xin lỗi xin
lỗi xin lỗi
vừa rồi hình như nó có cảnh báo Mấy ông
thấy không Đã ký kết này nó cảnh báo ADN
nó đọc hộ tôi
tiện ông ạ tôi không bị cái cảnh báo đây
À mà tối thiểu sửa lại nha
bây giờ mình làm nốt cái xóa là có nhiều
mình hoàn thành cho mùa hôm nay rồi
không nhắn mà đúng không Thì Cốt nó rất
là ngắn nó chẳng qua kiểu đấy em mới bây
giờ sẽ đổi nó sửa thành xóa này à
để anh ấy hiểu là bấm vào đây
em mình lại tạm lại khai báo tiếp trong
này mấy ông cứ điệp khúc Như thế nghĩa
thêm một cái gì đó mới sẽ thêm mát chờ
ngày mai cho một vài trường hợp với ông
sửa lại mô đen để các thử thôi Delete
này
cái này cầm lấy mã về này à
anh có đi qua Model và lại hết đầu có
trở lại
ở bên này copy cái này đổi Delete này
đây sẽ ra Delete
from sinh viên này que mã bằng mã chạy
sao chạy thử ở
anh không báo lỗi gì cả đúng không
anh
quay trở lại Ok ăn Xóa Xóa thêm
Ừ Ok sửa này
ở
đó ok đấy Đoàn toàn bộ tính năngxem thêm
thử Xóa r&d của MBC đồng thấy được mà nó
sẽ chia nhỏ ra rất là nhiều file Có
những file mấy ông trả lời động vào nữa
giống như cái nick này các bạn chắc là
chị gọn Quân cho lợn thôi nhưng có những
file
ở đoạn này thì file này bạn chất là nó
là nó sẽ nhận người yêu cầu của ông về
đúng không Nó sẽ nhận yêu cầu của ông về
sau đó thì nó sẽ gọi đến tùy từng trường
hợp nó sẽ gọi đến những cái á chân cần
thiết đấy
Sau đó thì thằng mua đồ thế sẽ có những
Asen nào đó sẽ xử lý gì đó như này đúng
không ạ
vào đây phải view rửa ra Các bạn thấy
rất cấp 3 giống đồ ăn một chẳng cái gì
cả đúng không phải view này là cụ giống
hệt
Ừ thôi đoán một nó không phát gì cả cái
thứ khác duy nhất ở đây các bạn phải cân
trailer và mua đồ không ạ Cái này các
bạn thấy hoàn toàn là nó sẽ kiểu nó sẽ
hợp lý hơn sau đón một là các bạn sẽ
cách xử lý hết ở trong file view for
view bây giờ không có xử lý gì cả gần
như chỉ để hiển thị mấy ông thấy không
thì anh hiển thị ra thôi à
ở những cái file liên quan xử lý dữ liệu
thì nó sẽ nằm ở phang mua đồ file xử lý
logic các thứ kiểu điều hướng yêu cầu
hoặc nó lấy yêu cầu về sẽ phai
controller đấy Mỗi file có một nhiệm vụ
riêng của nó như thế
đấy là cách làm hiệu cổ của MBC đó Trông
thấy được à Tính ra là gộp lại toàn bộ
nhưng cái file này số dòng ấy nó vẫn
ngắn hơn so với đồ ăn 1 của mấy ông làm
xem thêm sửa xóa
ở chỗ con ếch à cho con Nách nó cho con
ếch này có gì là được hả mời các bạn nhớ
đóng đóng kết nối nhá quên đấy các bạn
thì đó ngay tại đây được bởi vì việc các
bạn thì gọi đến file-model chắc chắn nó
sẽ luôn con ếch rồi mình sẽ luôn đóng ở
dưới đấy
khi nghe xong
giọng mẹ tôi à
khi chuyển các phần trên level 3 tất cả
chỉ máy mu đúng không ạ Mỗi cái phải tạm
một trang riêng rồi cho Linh vô hả anh ờ
riêng về vụ menu vừa rồi mình có nói thì
thì các bạn à
Ồ sướng nhất là câu TP về cơ bản nó sẽ
vẫn luôn Lát lại cha nó không có lót một
phần của trang đâu bếp bên nó không được
coi trời Loan một phần của cha kiểu gì
nó cũng vẫn lo lại trang cho dù ở rõ
ràng là cái giao diện ở ví dụ menu hay
tiêu đề hết đôi thì nó vẫn không thay
đổi nhưng mà nó vẫn Loan lại thì còn
cách để mà nhúng ố vàng như nào thì đến
là Zen thì mình bắt đầu dạy các bạn về
mình cái vụ đấy Và bây giờ mình sẽ dạy
các bạn mở xe những cái form Cơ bản cái
xăng nằm ở giữa phần bỏ đi thôi Tôi
không dạy mày ông về việc thêm menu các
thử như thế nào
Ừ thì cái này là con mấy cây ở trên công
ty của tôi nên tôi chưa cái rất nhiều
cái còn con laptop của tôi bị hỏng rồi
mà tôi khuyên mày ông nên chuyển qua dần
sang một IDE nào đó để cốt các thứ mấy
ông bà cũng được Vậy việc nó sẽ tối ưu
hơn rất nhiều nó hỗ trợ mày ông rất
nhiều Và thậm chí về đã rất nhiều lúc
cái file này hỗ trợ tôi cậu cốt kiểu nó
thông báo như này biến còn tồn tại hay
biến gì gì đó thôi còn khắc phục kiểu
như thế í e bản chất là nó lại hỗ trợ
con người mà tại sao mấy ông này lại
thích cốt mấy cái cậu thắp với Tech nó
vẫn hỗ trợ nhở trị hỗ trợ việc ta
gợi ý rồi chữ nổi phòng hỗ trợ ngon được
đi bắt ốc
U50 rồi mấy ông có thể chuyển qua Ngoại
Quốc bằng Word để nó luyện ông phần
chính tả cũng được
I wanna sẽ báo lỗi chính tả của mấy ông
hiểu chưa ạ
về cái vụ cam rồi lớn nhất à Có một sự
thật đó là laptop của tôi không có cam
và máy cây của tôi thì trái sẵn không
màu cam hay ra tội không hi vọng về Cam
thứ hai đó là tôi sẽ muốn ra mấy ông chỉ
tập trung vào nhìn màn hình tôi không mà
nhìn tôi một phần mà tôi nhiều lúc trong
trong bộ dạng ví dụ bây giờ tôi là mặc
đúng bộ đồ ngủ này mà không hẳn là đồ
ngủ mà
nó là đồ giữ nhiệt trong nó không đẹp
lắm với nó là đúng kiểu đồ lót của
khi dùng tỉnh em cho xem mấy ông dễ hình
dung nhé
Quảng cáo quảng cáo
bí thư hộ không ăn được tiền quảng cáo
nhưng mà
tôi mặc đồ giữ nhiệt Uniqlo bị tôi con
người rất là gầy kết hợp được cả miền
đất vừa rồi lạnh vãi nên này rõ kiểu sẽ
cần phải cái đồ giữ nhiệt đây nó có công
nghệ đồ rồi tắt đủ mặc mình trong tôi
còn mặc cái kiểu Tôi mặc quần như này
nhiều người nó là quần tất mà chồng
không đẹp lắm cái hợp với tôi mặc đang
mặc đồng nghệ áo như thế này áo này áo
đã thế còn cổ v để mà để mà phù hợp mặc
ở bên trong và không để lộ cổ ra tôi mua
bộ tôi thử cái mua bộ kiểu nhà để tôi
mặc sự nghiệp bên trong cũng như là tôi
tôi khi mà tôi đi dậy Để tôi chỉ cần mặc
cái áo sơ mi ở ngoài quá ấm rồi là quần
ông quần áo ở ngoài hồn tôi đi rồi tôi
mặc đúng kiểu như thế là tôi có thể đứng
ở trên lớp kiểu không sợ bị lạnh đi rồi
tao mặc đúng còn lâu lắm cả áo sơ mi
trắng kết hợp với hai cái này bên trong
đấy à à à
em không đẹp mấy ông nhìn đâu mà tôi sẽ
thả không gỡ Mở cam
ý mình đó là đây vừa rồi nọ bắt lỗi
chính tả mỗi ngày nó thông báo gì nhỉ
bắt lỗi hình cản
Ừ đấy bởi vì nó không có tự trong từ
điển nó không tiếng Việt báo lỗi này
thấy không như nhung
Ừ nhưng mày đang nói mấy ông Nếu mà kiểu
muốn cái nào bán bộ chính tả
xí nghiệp Mở word mở
lên ngồi gõ đó cái đấy nó bắn lô 9 ạ ạ ạ
à à
từ hôm nay có bài tập chưa anh ạ Không
bài tập của tôi tội không hướng bài tập
thì cảm với ông sẽ chỉ cần làm lại toàn
bộ Mày chạy mà tôi đã dậy thôi
mấy ông cần phải xem lại kỹ là mấy cái
này không thắc mắc gì cũng được bởi vì
mình nếu mà một người mới thì ra học cái
này hơi có tài Ừ để mỗi buổi rồi có nhắc
lại máy đâu Mỗi buổi Tôi lại thêm cái
mới thêm cái mới nhưng mà ông cứ chỉ
ngồi hấp thụ lại toàn bộ Cái này được
rồi đấy Sau đó thì
Em sang bên Open là con lằng nhằng nữa
cơ nó phức tạp nữa cơ Nếu cứ ngồi gõ lại
được đồng này tốt rồi
Cái này vẫn là sang bên level thì ra đầu
dậy đúng ra speak các thử như thế nào
còn mới xây này thì là mình cũng chưa
dùng mới sẽ thuần mà nhung mấy cái A
tôi sợ Đúng rồi Tôi sợ nhan sắc của tôi
làm ảnh hưởng tập trung mấy ông ấy đến
hình là đằng sau tôi đôi khi có rất
nhiều đấy thứ gì đó nghe thôi
ở Avatar Mở ẩn danh để mở lên để tránh
được dính quảng cáo này nhưng nhưng mà
kiểu gì Vừa rồi tôi đang để điện thoại
gần tôi thằng ứng dụng Facebook nó cũng
nghe được tôi cô trò chuyện tôi và nóng
sẽ đề xuất ở tôi mua cái gì ở thôi
quảng cáo khi mà tôi không ăn được một
đồng tiền nào của nó hơi đang chị gợi ý
mấy ông mấy cái tiện thôi
ở cam nhân vật ảo bắt chước với anh Mạnh
Tuấn
ở cây công nhân vật ở đấy được thấy nhìn
nhìn lúc độ hay về sau có thấy đại trà
kết hợp việc à
một mình Ông ngồi ngắm cái đấy sang
nghĩa gì cả à
à À tôi đến nhân vật nữ gửi cha tôi sẽ
xem xét về nhân vật nữ xong rồi hồi
trước là tôi có cài cái ứng dụng những
kiểu để mà nói giọng lưỡi
vẻ hay đối diện sẽ gửi mấy cái vụ đấy à
không để tôi xem xét đâu nhé tôi không
hướng đến hẳn một thằng chị m dạng thành
chat như thế yêu nha à
cũng muốn tâm sự một tí mày ông một
hôm nay thử là kiến thức thế tôi vẫn
thấy sẽ không khó lắm nên mấy ông
anh có thể hấp thụ hết tất cả đúng ai
tôi cho xem mấy ông tôi đang lại cả lên
kít nghỉ à
anh xoay
à à Mới c d
E71
lủn như này Đâu nhưng mà Bởi vì có quá
nhiều Mai xưa về sau tôi sẽ dậy mày ông
ngoài việc đó Khi mà sang work dậy mấy
ông là hôm nay thêm tính năng gì Ghi cái
chú thích các thứ thứ nha cho nó ổn
mình tôi sẽ tâm sự gì nhỉ
Ừ ok à
mục đích chỉ để học thì cũng kết thúc
rồi Thôi chị hợp dạy cho một tiếng mấy
ông có thể tạm nghỉ học à bé ông có lấy
hỏi cậu có hỏi gì tôi sẽ trả lời sau này
ngoài gì mà có một tiếng mà đúng không
Không hẳn nhiều lắm
à à
ông cho chịu khó xem lại mình bây giờ
sau nhé
Mình video trước chứ
tôi tôi có vừa rồi tôi có nói giờ tôi
mang mày laptop đi sửa mà lời khuyên của
tôi khi mà đem máy đi sửa rồi mấy ông
nên đăng xuất mọi thiết bị ho cả bằng và
mày ông cũng nên ở
cho
nên một là nếu mấy ông ổn nhất ấy nếu có
thể và có thời gian đấy mày không và mấy
cái lỗi đấy kiểu dạng là tạm biệt vệ
sinh máy cài lại máy gì gì đó giả sử Mấy
ông không muốn tự cài mang sang cài được
ạ Còn nếu không biết cài thì ra chị e
con cái suy nghĩ thôi bây giờ xuống béo
không biết thì mày ông
cho nên đứng đấy trực tiếp quan sát thì
càng tốt nếu mày không có thời gian còn
không thì mấy ông đăng xuất mọi thứ ra
rồi à mày Ông bảo người ta thảo ông ổ
cứng ra của ông cầm về nếu như trong
trường hợp của tôi về máy tôi cần phải
kiểm tra lại từ đầu đến cuối không mất
vài ngày cơ nên là mấy ông cứ bảo người
ta tháo ổ cứng ra à
người ta có thể lấy được dữ liệu hay gì
đó lại cảm của mấy ông
mà
100 lý do 19 triệu hiện đích khi mày
không phải xem lại những video trước
em à Giờ mình học lại khóa cơ bản
Ừ vẫn hộ hỗ trợ đồ án chứ các bạn hỏi gì
bây giờ mình trả lời thôi chứ bây giờ
thì còn về vụ kiểm tra đồ án được ra hơi
khó
Ừ ừ kiểm tra nếu mà có nhóm thì cho mình
sẽ hỗ trợ kiểm tra
các bạn Nói chung là các bạn cứ chủ động
nhắn mình thôi tất cả mọi thứ các bạn cứ
chủ động thôi mình cũng cũng hay quên đi
bật và cái hợp phải quên
tiếp theo là bảo vệ đồ án một thì chắc
là mình bảo phải đông đông một tí Mình
sẽ tổ chức hoa quả và rất riêng không
nói chuyện nữa
làm sao Mình chưa hiểu gì câu bạn lắm
ờ ờ
Excel vào database bằng pp được mà các
bạn chopa Excel nó sẽ có thu viện để nó
hỗ trợ vụ đấy
hình như không không thể ở dậy thì phải
à
à à
phần mô tả nhưng mà cũng hơi bị lừa
nghe trong phần mô tả mình có nên nói
nhưng mà shop thì không biết sớm nó có
ra được rất cả trong phần mô tả hay
không à
Ừ thấy khó đấy
à Tôi đang nghĩ là chắc là tôi sẽ phải
khi mà có rất nhiều cái dự định làm điện
hình giống như tôi bảo tôi cắt vài cái
video ngắn tự chó từ cái video dậy
ít người biết tôi hiện tại ngay bây giờ
ấy một đồng nếp này trên công ty rồi còn
đang giấy mà tôi vẫn còn đang tốn thời
gian để ngồi chỉ rõ đây thì hãy dùng từ
tốn thời gian được gì đấy mẹ tôi bảo thế
mà Mày dậy không mất tiền mà mày kiểu
dậy miễn phí mà mày có
không dám nghỉ buổi nào cho vợ Vân Anh
chưa hết
thì nói chung là tôi có thêm ra Hòa có
bạn nào mà giúp giống như hồi trước tôi
ở nhờ của bạn bây giờ bạn có bận giúp
tôi trưởng thứ nhất là bình luận là tôi
mấy cái phần mục lục của cái video ở tôi
copy cái đoạn đấy vào phần mô tả để mà
nó tự tự chia mục lục của cái video ra
này hợp việc giống như bạn cái bảo nếu
mà Mấy ông mà chịu khó xem lại hoặc tông
anh để mà xem biết được hôm đấy tôi nói
với mọi thứ gì so với ông ghi lại phần
đẩy trong phần mô tả không ạ để bình
luận để mà tôi sẽ sửa phần mô tả của tôi
khi chờ chưa tôi bảo tôi muốn xem lại
toàn bộ video của tôi
đi tìm mùa sữa từng cái A
đấy nhờ chắc chắn nó về sau tôi sẽ làm
hết mấy cái vụ đấy cô con tính làm nhiều
lắm
chỉ có một mình mình mà mình hơi bị tham
việc quá nhiều
khi tuyển hỗ trợ gửi nếu mà ông ông nào
thích thì mày ông vào bình luận giúp đỡ
cho các bạn thôi ngay ví dụ visa hôm nay
này mấy ông có thể bình luận luôn rồi
mấy ông giúp đỡ
à Mấy ông cứ bình luận rồi tôi sẽ chỉnh
sửa phần mô tả theo phần bình luận với
ông cái xong cái chẳng cần gửi tiền gì
cả Nói chung là tôi dậy vì cộng đồng thì
cộng đồng kiểu dạng là cũng giúp đỡ nhau
thôi chứ tôi có tội có kiểu dạng à
sự cầu kỳ làm cái này đó
Ừ cũng đúng ở visa chưa có nhiều gái tôi
sẽ không nhắn lại rồi nhưng lại hết ngày
mất
em Có phải ông mới mấy ông hơi bị thiệt
thì việc là không biết là mấy vụ đấy anh
em bé uống phải xem lại từ đầu đi
ờ ờ
không Không hẳn là kiểu chia hẳn thành
cái mục như thế đâu chỉ cần chia mục nó
lớn một tí không cần phải bé bé như thế
lớn tí dụng là bắt đầu buổi học tôi tôi
thường hay ở chia dạng là ban đầu buổi
học vào lúc mấy giờ à Lúc phút thứ mấy
này bắt đầu tâm sự Lúc mấy này đấy nếu
mà chia hẳn cái một con nữa thì Xịn quá
Nhưng mà nó nó sẽ có thể tốn thời gian
nhiều hơn
cho xem mặt lên Face của tôi có mặt đấy
à
vụ search được cái phần mô tả đâu Tôi
không chắc và vụ đấy đâu Tôi có để tự
thỉnh họa tôi chỉ có để hạt tác trong bể
phần mô tạ thôi nhưng mấy ông cha ơi con
được
a tiếp theo ở hôm trước tôi vào thằng
cách cái bồ thỉnh thoảng vẫn tái cái bồ
này nó vẫn bị đăng xuất ra rồi bạn thử
nhé
ừ ừ
nó bắt đầu lót Dinh nó mới kiểu thì nhớ
dùng cốc kỳ mình đăng nhập lại sẽ ngoài
thỉnh thoảng nó lại đang xuất đôi ra cảm
giác người dùng rất khó chịu được đấy
nhưng mà hôm trước thì đúng là nó đăng
xuất băng tôi ra thật và tôi cần phải
đăng nhập lại sau đó thì nó gửi mã mã
kiểu gần như ạ một cái vị một cái cốt về
giống rượu TP gửi về email để tôi đăng
nhập vào
da đã từng có vài trường hợp kiểu như
thế nó dặn chích boy để và các bạn biết
từ bên Facebook thể gọi nó cười thích
boy thì Ừ cái vụ đấy Tôi nghĩ là nó liên
quan việc là thằng tây Cái bồ này gần
đây nó bị dính lỗi bảo mật có thể để lộ
to Kem giống như thằng Facebook từng bị
thế này ra nó mới tự động đăng xuất
người dùng như thế à thế à trải nghiệm
người dùng thế không tốt về nhiều người
dùng quên mật khẩu hoặc không ấn lưu lưu
mật khẩu em ạ Đấy thì nhiều người người
dùng kiểu thế sẽ không tốt
à à kết hợp việc là nhưng mà cả đấy đôi
khi mấy ông chị nên làm 12 lần nên là
một hai lần thôi để mà Mấy ông Tăng bảo
mật giống như tôi bảo ấy thì bây giờ
thằng tây Cái bồ nó cho thêm cơ chế bắt
buộc phải nhập mã từ email thì mới truy
cập được vào ấy đấy
anh nói cho cứ khi tôi dùng cái đồ công
nghệ cậu một cái ứng dụng gì đó tôi sẽ
thử nghĩ xem Tại sao nó làm thế nó Vân
Tôi khuyên mày ông cậu nên nghĩ rằng
những cái đấy đúng không ạ
ở đấy và tương tự thế đó là mấy ông nên
về sau đấy biết động đang là ở công ty
đó là có cái vụ là đến số lần tính năng
hoạt động cơ sở như vừa rồi tao nói vụ
như vừa rồi ở cái mép Đăng xóa hết người
dùng ra sao rồi mấy ông có thể làm kế bộ
đếm cái phần tính năng quên mật khẩu
nhưng hạ Để xem à trong ngày hôm nay khi
mà bị là bụng đấy xong bao nhiêu người
ăn quên mật khẩu xong rồi hoa cả bao
nhiêu người gì gì đó Tại sao tự nhiên
tôi ở đề cập vụ đấy một việc thực sự là
nếu mà rửa sự bên ông làm kiểu cái đăng
nhập các thứ thứ quá khó khăn để người
dùng để luôn ấn vào quên mật khẩu hay là
luôn ấn vào cái gì đó hỗ trợ gì đó
có rất nhiều cái phần mềm tiền hình ở
tôi nói trong nước rồi kiểu dạng là cái
phần đăng nhập và rất khó chịu sử dụng
các khó chịu thì và mình nhắn tin cả
fanpage tôi nó sẽ phẳng nhắn tin fanpage
nữa cả Kiểu Đánh giá ứng dụng các thứ
trên cái cửa hàng đấy nó đều lồ cái gì
vậy Có phải lập trình viên Tôi khẳng
định lập trình viên mì cốt mà nó bị bị
sao ấy
Ở chỗ đầu cứng hai ta ơi nó kệ việc
người dùng vào đăng nhập không vào được
sẽ khiến người dùng ghét cái phần mềm
đấy và bắt đầu nghĩ sang dùng của đối
thủ đúng ạ Tại sao đăng nhập còn phải
khiến cho chúng ta khó khăn không ạ Đấy
thì
những cái đấy mấy ông đôi khi nếu phải
thống kê xem lượng người dùng như kiểu
giống như ở ở trang web bán hàng của tôi
thống kê xem mà lượng người dùng kiểu ở
trang thanh toán
anh ở bên trên thanh toán đấy Tuy cầu
người ta bỏ cái đơn đấy bao nhiêu phần
trăm để và nó bỏ ở những bước nào nhiều
nhất để mà cải thiện bên đấy bọn tôi có
phải làm như thế bởi vì nó liên quan đến
thực sự đến ngoan khách hàng liên quan
đến Kiểu cái chốt của một cái đơn hàng
cái gì đó không ạ Còn bây giờ tôi thấy
nhan nhản kiểu rất nhiều người phản hồi
tiêu cực về một cái ứng dụng nào đó
thằng Lập viên nó kêu đúng kiểu nó như
nó không bao giờ biết được điều đấy dạo
ấy nó vẫn kệ rất nhiều ứng dụng từ rất
lâu rồi rất là tệ mỗi phần đăng nhập
đăng nhập đi
Ý tôi nói thẳng luôn có hẳn một cái diễn
đàn lớn về công nghệ còn đang định tình
trạng đấy
có một tí nào luôn
I diễn đàn tôi không tiện Nó tên rồi tôi
từng bóc phốt tôi từng
nhắn tin fanpage câu thử vẫn tệ và một
loạt về phần mềm ngân hàng luôn ngân
hàng rất tệ chẳng qua mình lỡ đăng ký
ngân hàng ấy rồi à
nghe lời khuyên đấy Đó là mấy ông về sau
cũng là dân lập trình mạng mấy ông về xã
hội sẽ làm phần mềm mà Mấy ông đừng có
hành mèo hãy có tâm một tí đừng có hành
khách hàng nha như những người đấy
a tiếp theo à
được 19 triệu
Ừ nhưng mà tôi không Tôi không thí
nghiệm thực tế của tôi Đúng rồi chị Hơn
2 năm rồi nhưng mà
chuẩn mức lương thôi không phải 19 triệu
đó
không vô dâu nó còn chán em
Ừ nó chính là diễn đàn vibro
Ừ tôi từng hay đọc ở trên đấy chia sẻ
rất nhiều cái hay nhưng khẳng định cái
phần đăng nhập làm mọi do diện rất ổn
hơn bên web mà lý ra vẫn ổn nhưng mà ác
thì hỏng lên Hồng xuống rồi áp giao diện
rất là tệ xong rồi hình cái đội tôi nhắn
tin mấy lần rồi thì như cái đội đẹp ở áp
ở bên này cái Bỏ rồi phải bây giờ nó vẫn
tệ
vì nó không đăng nhập được chuyện tình
khùng à
kế tiếp nhau những bạn mà
cho những bạn không theo kịp bây giờ ra
là có khá nhiều bạn còn bây giờ mới bắt
đầu học những cái buổi các bạn của mình
đừng có thấy thấy điều đấy của vì lượng
người xem những bộ Cơ bản mình hôm trước
vẫn vẫn đang lên thì cái này thực ra
không khó khó mà
em hỗ trợ được yêu tất cả Bây giờ tôi
vẫn chỉ đang hỗ trợ nhấn bạn hiện tại
thôi thì những bạn ấy vẫn là chịu khó
hiểu xem xem lại nhưng mà
Ừ cái hay ở đây thì thì mấy ông vẫn có
cái gì xem lại không ạ
Và mấy ông hỏi tôi tôi cũng trả lời được
anh nói chung là hy vọng với ông không
bị làm thôi Bởi vì thực ra có nhiều Ông
tìm đến kênh của tôi tôi tôi bảo tìm em
kênh tôi thì 11 phần nào cho vui một
phần cậu vào xem thoại nói cái gì tao
chặn họng nó hạn và nhưng mà 3 số thì sẽ
là những người mà kiểu thực sự muốn theo
ngày nay cảm thấy kiểu một là học trên
lớp và chưa đủ hay là
kẹo muốn tìm một cái lồi rồi đi riêng
mới đúng không ạ
bởi vì nhàng bạn ấy có thể chọn Nó không
phù hợp bây giờ các bạn vẫn sẽ phải tự
lực là nhiều
hôm chỗ tôi bảo gì à cam kết à cam cam
kết bảo hành trọn đời không ạ Mà rõ dài
không thu đầu nào nhưng vẫn cam kết và
anh trọn đời đúng không những là mấy ông
mấy ông mày ông kiểu dạng là có thắc mắc
từ đảm bảo đầu ra là xong rồi đang bận
công việc đấy tôi cũng một đồng D cho
mấy ông mấy ông thích chọn cái gì thì
chọn bờ quyền lựa chọn nó cùng với ông
Mạnh hoặc Không chọn nữa chịu
a
man ăn rồi mà chưa Đi vệ sinh á 6 thái
địa sinh một lần đi em ạ
cái tâm sự không liên quan dân công nghệ
Nhờ cái này một mẹo Hồi chiều tao tán
gái giờ hay chia sẻ và
hi vọng các bạn nữ ở đây
ở tạm tắt máy không biết được điều này
mày ông có trai nghe kỹ nhé đó là
Ừ cái này thì con nói chung luôn đó là
thứ con gái nói chung là về lý trí không
không tỉnh táo lắm nhưng mấy bạn con
trai
Chú ý nhớ về quản lý trí về cảm tính thì
vẫn nhiều hơn tí Thế nên có rất nhiều
lúc bạn ấy đang rất là giận ông đang sẽ
là cậu rỗi hai cái gì ở vân vân ông có
rất nhiều cách để mà khiến cho
tôi không giỏi dỗ Tôi không phải dõi nhé
Thì nhưng mà một trong những cách
Ừ để khiến bạn bậy bạn quên đi mà cách
ông nhắn tin với gì đó thôi mà sai lỗi
chính tả bạn sẽ Soi lỗi chính tả ông vừa
nhắc thì cái đấy và quên mình đang giận
mày ông không biết là mày Ông đã biết
cái mẹo Chưa từng làm thế à
à mà khá thành công khá nhiều lần mà đổi
kiểu bạn đấy bật cười cậu khi mà bạn đầy
đang rất giận ông cơ tương tự Thế có rất
nhiều cái kiểu Nếu có thể đánh trống
lảng như đánh trống màn Cậu dặn à
cách lộ liễu một tí cũng được để bạn ấy
nhận ra đấy à
em cũng một cách nói chung của tôi đã
từng áp dụng khá nhiều cách để mặc cố
tình đánh trống lảng và làm để quên đi
cái mục đích ban đầu bạn ấy khiến là bạn
đấy cậu ạ cảm thấy dọn như này
ờ ờ
tìm hiểu một bạn thì cái bạn đấy Lúc đầu
bạn đấy cũng kiểu dạng là bạn cũng sẽ
trừng tôi hiểu bạn này cũng cậu
cái lúc một lúc mà tôi nhắn tin đấy bạn
ơi đã có suy nghĩ là kiểu là sẽ không sẽ
không nhận lời không không hiểu rảnh
không để cho anh này có có cơ hội Tiến
không có hội một cơ hội luôn ngay từ lúc
đầu định từ chối luôn đấy Đấy sau đó thì
tôi kiểu ngồi nói chém gió xong rồi nói
đủ thứ từ rất đàng hoàng thùy hư để
khiến nó bảo quên đi hẳn mục đích ban
đầu bởi định định nói định phủ ngoài đầu
so với cùng thì về sao bị cuốn theo câu
chuyện quên sẽ luôn rồi mãi kiểu bây giờ
vậy Mình nhớ ra lúc đấy hết rồi Kiểu
đang đang nói chuyện chán thế Đang kiểu
đã hợp rồi chẳng ai tự nhiên bị từ chối
đúng không Đấy con gái chị sẽ luôn có
mức sự dè chừng và luôn kẹo nghĩ trước
vạch trước thấy gì ở trong động nhưng mà
các bạn ấy không kiến định làm đâu Mẹ ơi
mày ông mặt thay đổi được cái cái đấy mà
để khiến bạn ấy tặng ngồi đi lúc sau bạn
ấy mua hẳn bạn sẽ không nhắc lại mấy đâu
hơn Ơ Đúng là sang cả đôi khi là bạn ấy
sẽ giận ông gửi việc ông xanh thả Chắc
chắn rồi nhưng quan trọng là ông chị ứng
dụng chiêu này khi mà bạn còn bạn ấy còn
đang giận ông cái thứ gì đó còn ghê gớm
hơn thì hay việc đấy Bạn ấy giận ông về
các lỗi chính tả bé không chỉ cần xin
lỗi rồi lỗi chính tả nó dễ hơn đúng
không nào cũng gửi cho thì béo không dỗ
được mình cái trả lời mày không phải dấu
chuyện bé
Ừ ông kia là tôn chích xong rồi đi thanh
nhã ảnh ảnh avatar là hacker à ok
về cả công nghệ vật lạ cá thứ tâm sự
tình cảm mày mày Ông còn thắc mắc gì
Ê mày không còn thắc mắc thì tôi sẽ chia
sẻ thêm nhiều cái sau
như đây Cái gì nhỉ à
Ừ cái lâu lắm bảo định với những câu hỏi
AD một mẹo của Swift nó không trùng con
sâu lóc nữa mà mấy ông để chuyển qua con
số Thay bồ này thì thị giác đi bộ hoặc
hoặc là con số cậu lót lại thời gian bắt
đầu được gắn kết thúc trở lại giữa này
phải cho đến khi sao thì những cái thùng
cái này vào cản em một mẹo thôi mày Ông
cố tỏ ra Speed nhiều thì sẽ biết mẹ này
ta sẽ sẽ thấy mẹ mày hay
ở tại mày thấy rồi sẽ là tôi hết thứ
chia sẻ với ông rồi em mấy giờ ông này
bắt đầu xin lại ạ
Ừ nó kênh mình về sau sẽ có sót chưa có
anh nói chung là tạm thì thấy hết
em hết cái hôm nay có thể nói rồi tâm sự
cũng chán chê rồi ngoài tạm nghỉ đâu nhỉ
À
thì các bạn có thắc mắc gì thì chắc là
để các bạn bình luận hoặc nhắn tin hoặc
buổi sau nha Với sau mấy ông cũng nên
tôi tổng hợp câu hỏi rồi thì béo cũng
nên tổng hợp có hỏi mà hỏi tôi đúng
không béo Mày liệt kê danh sách ra để
hôm sau khỏi một loạt sẽ phù hợp hơn mấy
ông có khuyến khích mà ông hỏi mà Bởi nó
sẽ rèn tư duy ông ạ Ông không phải mỗi
nhận thông tin đấy ông sẽ phải xử lý
thông tin và ông thậm chí ở ông sẽ nó
cái việc của trò chuyện hay chiều sẽ
luôn khiến mình đập não hơn mà Ừ thôi
tặng nghĩa nhỉ Sao mày không